you know it's all about honesty I reckon
you know honesty is I think hon like
cheating wouldn't be a thing if it was
for the honesty side of things you know
I mean depending on what you're looking
for see like in in 2023 now yeah um even
myself I've been involved in a in a
frapple yeah he only for a couple of
weeks and that and well I've got two
girlfriends and my girlfriends are
girlfriends well not currently it's not
the situation been doing it wrong the
whole time
so that's a that's a thropple you
know what I mean and
um yeah but it's just a case of honesty
you know what I mean so I was honest
with them they were honest with me no
one got hurt in the process how the
did you pull that off seriously it 20
it's like 23% of women are actually open
to that where only 6% of men are red